tony allen et travailleur social
installé à nyon il est coordinateur d'un
j'aime un groupe d'entre aide mutuelle
en temps normal ils portent assistance à
plus de 70 personnes qui souffrent
d'isolement et d'exclusion sociale
depuis un peu plus d'un mois son groupe
a dû mettre fin aux sorties et à tous
types d'activités collectives
le travail de tony selene se résume
désormais un suivi quotidien des
adhérents aujourd'hui elle combat dur
c'est quoi ton problème aujourd'hui
le travailleur social face en moyenne
six heures par jour au téléphone
beaucoup des adhérents du groupe
d'entraidé mutuelle souffre de troubles
psychologiques qu'exacerbe le
confinement et l'isolément obligatoires
ces dernières semaines tony selene a
remarqué une augmentation de l'anxiété
chez ses adhérents
il regrette que les responsables
politiques ne les rassure pas vous
montez des angoisses nous on fait on
essaie de trouver des supports en fait
pour ainsi d'améliorer le quotidien des
gens ça devient de plus en plus
difficile et plus le confinement dure
dans le temps puis ça devient très très
difficile mais en même temps ça ne se
passe pas qu'au niveau des angoisses ya
des colères le problème c'est les médias
et les politiques qui sont absolument
pas rassurantes comme en fait foi la
pression qui ne se rend pas compte en
fait il ya énormément de gens qu'il faut
rassurer la situation veut que les gens
soient rassurés ce qui n'est absolument
pas le cas en france environ 350 gm ont
été créés en dix ans il regroupe plus de
quinze mille adhérents sur tout le
territoire
ce sont des espaces et des activités
pensée et organisée au quotidien par les
adhérents eux-mêmes avec l'aide
d'animateurs salariés et bénévoles
un principe rendu impossible par le
confinement qui brident cette chaîne de
solidarité